this blusher hack has the Beauty World
divided it's called the Sunkist skin
hack and it involves using a cream
blusher to draw in a raccoon shape
around your face starting in your
forehead coming down your temple and
then looping back over the bridge of
your nose
I used the Wonder stick blush by NYX and
my usual buffing brush
um but I didn't really rate the results
I feel like I looked just a little bit
red a little bit flushed and not that
sun-kissed so I went in instead with my
usual bronzing stick which is from Merit
buffed it out and actually re-rated the
results I feel like using a bronzer
instead of blush is maybe the way to go